it's the last day but it's actually
going to be an incredible day with some
really awesome talks
um so I thank you all for being here
this morning
um our uh I'll come back to some more
things later our our uh final keynote
speaker is Professor Eiffel Oscar from
Stanford University we've kept it a
little informal so I'm Margarita bio but
she's amazing and you'll find out from
her talk thank you thank you so much
Lolita and thank you so much for the
invitation to speak here
model but what could be better than
having a really awesome nature
that's called really juggling work like
that
okay so very happy to be here
um so in this talk I would like to tell
you about this notion of information
constraint optimal transport and this is
a story about how this notion emerged
when we were studying we were looking at
some very classical fundamental problems
in information Theory like the capacity
of the relay Channel and then how it
took us all the way to privacy in
generative adversarial Networks
um and so I've been working on this
topic on and off for quite a while now
so I'll try to summarize the main ideas
from a few of our papers
um and these are joint work with
different subsets of the people you see
here
so Daria rishatova and vening Chan are
my PhD students from Stamford when he is
here
um and you can buy and Shoe Bank who are
from the University of Delaware
and what we'll try to do in the soap is
to see how this notion of information
constraint optimal transport relates to
couple of things here uh the first thing
will be the work of the French
mathematician telegram his work on
Transportation costs inequalities
um and then we'll see how it relates to
the work of uh the famous information
theorist Catalin Martin so he her claim
to fame is to establish this connection
between Transportation costs
inequalities and concentration of
measure and then we'll see how this
notion emerges in the study of this
relay channel uh in a problem that's
formulated by Tom cover and finally I'll
tell you how this notion becomes useful
in the context of generative adversarial
networks and roughly I guess the plan is
to spend the first half of the talk on
these first three topics and then the
second I'll have on this on this last
topic
okay
okay so to tell you about uh information
constraint optimal transport I first
need to tell you about optimal transport
um and this is a problem that goes a
long way back to the French
mathematician move uh 1781 he is not on
land excavation and infield where he
formulates the following problem so he
says let's say we have we want to
excavate some land here or some
prescribed shape PX
and then we want to take the land we
excavate and transform it to this target
shape py
um and mass will be preserved here so
without loss of generality we can assume
that the total mass is normalized to one
so you can think of these shapes as
defining just uh probability
distributions
so now our problem can be stated as
follows
so let's say we have a random variable x
with this distribution PX
and then we would like to have them find
a mapping that will transform this
random variable X to this target random
variable y with this target distribution
UI so both PX and py are given to us and
among all such mappings that transform X
to Y we would like to find the one that
minimizes the expected volume of a given
cost function and the cost function
captures the cost of taking uh one unit
of mass from this point x and carrying
to this point Y so in most problem this
can simply be the distance between these
two points
okay and you can think of the
expectation here as carried over the
joint distribution of these random
variables so note that in the beginning
we start with just two marginal
distributions p x and P Y but once you
fix the coupling between them the
mapping this defines a joint
distribution for X and Y with these
marginals and then we are basically
trying to find the best coupling here
that minimizes this expected cost
sure and this problem gets rediscovered
some uh I guess uh 160 years later by
the Russian mathematician and economic
Economist cantarovich during uh the
world worth uh the World War II
um I guess at the time they need to deal
with a lot of logistical problems they
need to carry soldiers and goods between
different places so
um he he reformulates the problem and he
actually introduces a small but
important generalization in the
formulation
so in most formulation this mapping has
to be deterministic
um and that actually makes the problem
ill-defined in some cases for example if
you have just a one point Mass here so
if the source distribution is just a
point mass and you restrict the mapping
to be deterministic then you can't
create a shape like this because a
deterministic function cannot take one
point x and map it to the two different
points so you cannot split Mass with uh
deterministic mappings
and kankarovich allows this mapping to
be randomized in which case you can
think of it just as a conditional
probability distribution or a channel in
the information theoretic language a
channel that takes the input
distribution PX and transforms it to
this output distribution py and once you
fix that channel right this defines the
joint distribution for X and Y with
these prescribed marginals and again
among all such joint distributions which
is given marginals we would like to find
the one that minimizes the expected
value of a given cost function
okay and this turns out to be a very
fruitful area in mathematics that sees a
lot of famous names a lot of famous
awards uh so kantarovic gets the Nobel
Prize in 1975 uh for his work in this
area together with cookmans and then
they invent linear programming in this
context because if you go back this
problem is actually a linear
optimization problem because both the
objective here and these constraints
they are linear in this joint
distribution p
and it's an area that has found a lot of
applications also in many different
areas from economics to meteorology and
most recently in machine learning and in
the second half of the talk I'll try to
tell you about some of these
applications in machine learning
Okay so
for most of the stock we will fix the
cost function to be a specific cost
function and that would be the square to
euclidean distance between the two
points and that turns out to be a
natural cost function for a lot of
applications
and if you do that if you fix the cost
function to be this one and then you
take the square root of this optimal
cost then this resultant quantity
actually has a name of its own it's
called the quadratic washer Stein
distance
and one can actually check that it
defines a proper distance metric between
distributions
um so intuitively right if you have two
distributions uh that are very similar
to each other then the cost of
transporting one to the other will be
small right and if they are very
different the cost of transporting one
to the other will be large so you can
use this quantity to measure to define a
notion of distance and measure
similarity dissimilarity between
distributions
and one research line that has been of
significant interest in in mathematics
is the development of so-called
Transportation cost inequalities
that bound this quantity here so this is
a famous One by telegram from 1996.
um which says the following so now if
you take one of these distributions here
to be the gaussian distribution with
zero mean and identity covariance
metrics then this inequality says that
the squared washer Stein distance
between this gaussian distribution and
any other distribution is always bounded
by two times the KL Divergence between
these two distributions
okay and I guess one way to interpret
this inequality would be that okay we
can use washer Stein distance to measure
similarity between distributions KL
Divergence is another measure for
measuring similarity the similarity
between distributions so this inequality
says that this measure is always bounded
by two times this measure
but the reason why these Transportation
cost inequalities have been of
significant interest in mathematics is
because people have shown that for
example Transportation cost inequalities
of this form can be used to prove
measure concentration results and this
is actually the major contribution of
Catalin Martin to establish that
connection from Transportation cost
inequalities to concentration results
which roughly say that if you have a
nice smooth function
that depends on a lot of independent
random variables then this function will
concentrate around its mean
exponentially fast and indeed the
transportation costs inequality from the
previous slide can be used to prove this
gaussian measure concentration result
and then people have also shown that
these kind of results are also
essentially equivalent they capture the
same phenomena a so-called isoparametric
inequalities in Geometry which at first
seem completely unrelated
um so what are isopy metric inequalities
I'm sure everyone is familiar with the
isoparametric inequality on the plane at
least at an intuitive level right which
says that if you draw shapes on the
plane two-dimensional shapes like this
with the same perimeter ISO perimetric
means same perimeter then the circle
will be the one that maximizes its area
for a given perimeter
and actually that Transportation costs
inequality from the previous slide can
be shown to be essentially equivalent to
an isoparametric inequality in gaussian
space meaning that when the measure in
the space is is given by the gaussian
distribution
okay so there are some interesting set
of connections here between kind of
problems that at first seem quite not
that related to each other
okay so any questions so far this was
more or less the background on optimal
transport
so what I would like to do next is to
define the quantity that will be our
main focus in this talk which will be a
variation of this notion of
um optimal transport or washer Stein
distance
and we'll call it uh information
constraint optimal transport
okay so what is this quantity so
remember in the definition of the washer
Stein distance right we have this
optimization over all possible joint
distributions with these prescribed
marginals right so what we would want to
do now is we would want to constrain
these joint distributions by saying that
the mutual information disjoint
distribution induces between X and Y
cannot exceed a given threshold so in
this optimization we only consider joint
distributions that induce a bounded
Mutual information between X and Y so
smaller than a given threshold
we'll call that information constraint
washer sign Divergence now because
technically speaking it's not a distance
metric once you introduce this
constraint especially the viewers
passing through a specific family of
channels yes yes exactly so what this
constraint does is remember in the
beginning I told you that in most
formulation the mapping has to had to be
deterministic right and then we said
cantaro which relaxed it to a low for uh
randomized mappings right but it turns
out that in a lot of interesting uh
non-degenerate cases even though ulo for
randomized mappings the optimal mapping
still turns out to be deterministic and
in some cases you may want to enforce
some amount of noise randomization in
that mapping and this is exactly what
the mutual information constraint does
right because if the mapping between X
and Y is deterministic X is a function
of Y
then this Mutual information here can be
potentially very large even unbounded in
the continuous case and what this
constraint does is is basically it
limits that Mutual information and by
basically controlling this R you can
control how much run randomization you
want in this mapping in the limit I
guess if you take R to be zero then the
mutual information has to be zero this
means that the only coupling ulo here
joint distribution is the independent
one okay
and we'll see some other reasons why one
may want to look at this quantity but
this can be this is what the constraint
does
okay and the first thing we'll do is uh
we'll show a basically an upper bound on
this now information constraint washer
Stein Divergence that has a similar
flavor to telegrams inequality
um in the sense that we fix one of the
marginals here to be a gaussian
distribution and we say that the squared
information constraint washer Stein
Divergence between the scausion and any
other distribution
has to be bounded by this right hand
side which is now more complicated so it
depends on two parameters related to
this x distribution the second moment
and the entropy and it also depends on
the r the amount of the the constraint
on the mutual information
okay so why is this interesting well I
guess the first thing you can do here
you can as a sanity check you can take R
to infinity and when you take R to
Infinity you're essentially removing
this constraint so this quantity just
reduces to standard washer style
Investments and then you see you can see
what you get on the right hand side and
compared compare it to the right hand
side of talagrance inequality
um
and if you do that uh basically you can
this is what you get and you can prove
that this inequality is always tighter
than telegram's inequality and actually
it's achieved with equality for a
slightly wider class of distributions as
compared to telegrams inequality but I
think more interestingly it turns out
that this inequality also has a natural
counterpart in this ISO parametric World
it turns out that this one captures the
isoparametric inequality on the sphere
which says that if you live now on the
surface of an n-dimensional sphere and
you ask the same question among all sets
on the surface of the sphere
um with the same perimeter with the same
neighborhood on the sphere what is the
one that maximizes its measure its area
it turns out to be the spherical cap so
that's the iso parametric inequality on
the sphere and what you see there is is
in its heart saying the same thing as
this isopenetric inequality
okay it turns out that the more General
version with the mutual information
constraint that also has a natural kind
of counterpart as an isoparometric
inequality and its corresponds to some
some strengthening of this uh of this
ISO parametric inequality on the sphere
okay
and okay all this for us really started
when we we were we were looking at this
problem uh so this classical problem in
information Theory the capacity of the
relay Channel we were intrigued by a
version of this problem that was
formulated by Tom cover in this book
open problems in communication and
computation in the 80s
um and then at some point we were able
to solve this problem
um but then the first proof we came up
with was quite complicated and long and
we always felt like for for a year after
that we felt like there must be a more
direct way to make the same argument
um and I guess if you stare for at
something for long enough then it comes
to you at some point we realize that but
that long proof was really doing was
proving that Transportation cost
inequality on that information
constraint uh washer Stein Divergence
and once you have that inequality then
you can actually prove the result for
for for this problem just in couple of
lines
and I guess this is for people who have
looked at these kind of problems in
information Theory
um so the way we use this inequality is
at a very high level right so we are
actually trying to prove a Converse for
the capacity of the relay Channel and
when you prove a Converse you always
start with this funnels inequality to
say that the block length times the
capacity is smaller than the mutual
information between the inputs to your
channel uh and the outputs collected by
the destination and in this relay
Channel problem there are two of them
one from the direct link and one from
the relay
um and then what we do is so there are
some n-dimensional variables right
associated with this problem and what we
do is we keep we take certain marginals
associated with this problem
um and then we couple them
so basically we are creating if you like
a new set of random variables where
certain marginals are preserved but but
certain marginals are coupled with each
other they have dependence now and then
we bounce this Mutual information in
that new kind of setting that they
create where things are coupled with
each other
um but because certain marginals are
preserved this Mutual information is
preserved
um and I guess in that new setting
bounding this becomes immediate with
this inequality okay so this is a very
high level idea if it makes any any
sense to people
okay so and once we finish this work I
was really excited because
um I felt like this quantity uh not just
I mean because it emerged in this relay
Channel but in itself I thought it was a
very natural thing to study information
constrained washer Stein Divergence and
I guess it turns out that if something
is very natural then it's very likely
that it also showed up in other people's
work so I think I read this in a paper
by Jack Wolf he said something like
um every new good idea is a
Reincarnation of an old good idea and
this was certainly the case here so it
turns out that this quantity we realized
can be traced back all the way to
Schrodinger 1931 and this was even
before kantarovich formulated the
optimal transport problem this is even
before the axioms of probability were
there and obviously he didn't State his
problem in these terms exactly but if
you look at the heart of what he was
doing it was related to this to this
notion yeah
and then we also realized that this
quantity actually in this lagrangian
form right so this is a constraint
optimization problem here and you can
take this constraint and you can make it
part of your objective here by
introducing a LaGrange multiplier and
this this version has been of
significant interest in the recent
machine learning literature and it goes
under the name entropy regularized
optimal transport and Tropic washer
Stein distance sinkhorn Divergence and
so on
um I just I guess I'll just call it
information constraint washers time
Divergence for consistency throughout
the stock but the reason why people in
the machine learning literature has been
have been interested in this in this
notion is is mainly for computational
reasons
because they want to compute the regular
washer spine distance without the
Smoochum information
um but without the mutual information I
mean Computing the washer Stein distance
involves solving this optimization
problem right overall couplings here
overall joint distributions and that
that optimization problems turns out to
be computationally prohibited for many
it's a linear program but the
computational complexity is still high
for many of the uh problems we would
like to solve in practice so instead
they introduced the mutual information
and that this makes the optimization
problem strongly convex and then you can
then solve it much more efficiently
compute this one much more efficiently
than the original one so you you
basically just compute this one and then
take it as a proxy for the true washer
Stein distance
okay and obviously this computational
aspect is very important but I guess for
me as an information tourist it's more
interesting to think about what adding
this Mutual information to your problem
now does to your Solutions right
um and now in the rest of the talk I'll
try to tell you a little bit about that
in the specific context of generative
adversarial networks because this is one
area where this washer spine distance
has been uh has has has proven quite
useful
okay so what are generate generative
adversarial networks so these are a
popular method today for learning
distributions from data by modeling your
target distribution as a function of a
known distribution okay so you're trying
to learn a mapping here which is called
the generator
and it's usually represented by a neural
network
um and you want this generator this
mapping to be able to take samples from
this known distribution and transform
them to samples from this from this
target distribution
and you can formulate this as an
optimization Problem by fixing uh
basically a loss function here and a way
to measure the distance between your
generated distribution at the output of
the generator and the target
distribution and one popular metric for
that is the washer sign distance
um and then you you basically have to
solve this optimization problem here you
have to find the best mapping the best
generator in a given class that
minimizes the washerstein distance
between
the generated distribution at the output
and the target distribution py
but a lot of times you won't know what
the target distribution is you just have
samples from that Target distribution so
the target distribution here will have
to be replaced by the empirical
distribution of your n samples so
instead of solving the previous problem
you solve this one here with the
empirical distribution
and yes they've been obviously very
successful they have demonstrated
impressive results in a lot of different
domains but they also have a number of
issues like they they are slow they they
suffer from slow conversions
um they they suffer from stability
issues and one difficulty is that it's
sometimes difficult to
quantitatively evaluate the performance
of a generator you learn because you
don't know what the optimal solution is
so it's difficult to say how close you
are to an optimal solution
and to get some insight on some of these
problems there was a paper by one of my
colleagues groups David Che at Stanford
and his students couple of years ago
where they proposed to evaluate Gans on
a very simple benchmark
um so this is the gaussian linear
setting a very simple setting where um
this input distribution here is gaussian
zero mean identity covariance metric
Dimension R are small uh and then the
target distribution here is also
gaussian zero mean let's say covariance
KY and the dimension D is now larger
than than r
and the generator is restricted to be
linear
in which case you can think of it just
as a matrix that takes samples of
Dimension R and Maps them to samples of
Dimension d
um and obviously because the output is a
linear transformation of this input
which is gaussian the output will also
be gaussian in this case but it will be
a degenerate gaussian distribution
because the covariance Matrix can be at
most of rank R because the input is of
Dimension R and the question is
basically what G here will will minimize
the distance between the output
distribution the gaussian you are able
to generate and the target gaussian here
um and it's not too difficult to show
that uh the optimal G here will come
from the rpca solution of Y so meaning
that you will look at the uh our top
eigenvalues of Ky and the corresponding
eigen uh eigenmodules and eigenvectors
and and this G will have will have those
same topic top R eigen modules and or I
should say the covariance metrics of the
distribution you create here will match
this covariance Matrix in the top are
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
okay
okay so in this simple setting we know
what the optimal G is okay if we know
that the target distribution is gaussian
with this covariance Matrix we know that
the optimal G Star comes from this rpca
solution
but in practice you can't solve this
problem because you don't know the
target distribution instead you only
have samples from this distribution so
instead you need to solve this problem
where the target distribution is
replaced by the empirical distribution
of the samples that come from the same
distribution we'll call this our
empirical solution we'll call that the
population solution
foreign
very simple linear gaussian setting the
convergence of this GN to G Star will be
very very slow in the following sense so
if you look at your washer Stein
distance to the Target distribution
and the output of the empirical
generator versus the washerstein
distance between the target distribution
and the generated distribution by the
optimal generator so ideally right if GN
is close to G Star you want these things
to be the same so the difference to
converge to zero and it does converge to
zero but very very slowly with n where n
is the number of samples we have so the
exponent of n here is 2 to the D where D
is the dimension of the output so this
means that even if the dimension of the
output is something like 20 the
conversions here is very very slow so
even in the simple setting
um you need a lot of a lot of samples in
order to converge to the optimal to the
true solution
and when we when this notion of
information constraint washerstein
Divergence emerged in our work the first
thing we wanted to do is to
um basically see what will happen to the
conclusions of this paper if we replace
the washer sign distance now with this
information regularized washer sign
distance washer Stein Divergence
um and you can do that so the problem is
the same just that now our loss function
changed from the regular washer time
distance to this information regularized
washers time distance and here you can
show a couple of things you can first
show that in this gaussian linear
setting you can again characterize the
optimal solution
and indeed we see that when you add the
mutual information the optimal solution
changes so regularizing with the mutual
information actually changes the
generator you learn and the generator
you learn is now a kind of soft
threshold that rpca meaning that you'll
take the top R eigen volumes of that
Target covariance metrics but you would
actually
eliminate some of them that are smaller
than a given threshold so you will
further sparsify you will reduce further
reduce the rank of your generated
distribution
and then we can also show that um if you
do this and not only for the gaussian
linear case but when as long as this PX
and P Y are sub gaussian and the set of
generators is either the set of linear
generators or lipstick generators you
can basically show that with the mutual
information regularization now you'll
get much faster conversions to to the
optimal generator here so now the
convergence here will be like 1 over
square root of n so we can get rid of
that dependence uh in the exponent of n
to the dimension D we don't have it we
don't have an exponent anymore that
decreases with the dimension
so regularizing with this Mutual
information can enable faster
convergence
any questions by the way I didn't stop
for questions but you're always welcome
to possible
distance just for the course of the
nationality will that help here or is it
how is it related I think so I think so
basically our result so so usually as
far as I'm aware the kind of results
that zip is looking at is more about
just the conversions of the washer Stein
distance
um between if you take two empirical
distributions right for PX and py and
you study how fast the washer Stein
distance between the two empirical
distributions converges to the
um to much as time distance between the
two distributions what we do here is we
build on those kind of results but there
are extra steps that you need to take
care of here because this in this case
PX and py the two distributions tend to
be they are actually correlated with
each other because one is generated as a
function of the other so you have to
handle that dependence
um and also you want the result for the
minimum for the best G which doesn't
mean so so basically I'm saying if there
is a result like that it's possible that
you can work out the corresponding
result for from again case yes but we
didn't try that specifically yeah so um
so they try so much information I
understand the connection with the relay
Channel but you're in these uh and I I
know Marco polteri's work and I know
that this is this really nice simple
single and optimal optimal transfer
algorithms but um the choice of which
information is still a little bit
arbitrary
so have to explore the other
um options as well like some other
versions instead of you know Divergence
um
I should say no the other thing we
explored was you can take a version of
this virtual information regularization
uh basically you can because this is
biasing the solution and you can de-bias
it but it's still regularizing by Mutual
information basically and then you can
you can you can basically have your most
function recover the RPC solution
exactly but we didn't try uh other other
dimensions yeah that would be
interesting I guess for me it was really
like there was this quantity that
emerged and I was really excited about
it and I wanted to understand what else
this can be useful for and this is one
thing that it can be useful for but uh
obviously it's possible that you can get
similar kind of results with other
there
are other loss functions we have to
apply for them Maxwell's question then
I'll ask a question later all right well
first first election was really funny
when when you mentioned Steve my first
thought was Jacob's here because I'm old
that's right
Tim did this anyway but um I just wanted
to uh also point out uh the work of
Saudi Lindo new cell on this information
because what they call information uh
velocity Source coding with with the
constrained output distribution where
they considered minimizing expected
Distortion between X and Y subject to
Marginal constraints on X and then Y and
neutral information in X and Y
um and so they actually had very
interesting connections kind of a
structural structural results for these
things where they said you can actually
use optimal transport as a building
block of these of these calls
yeah I should have mentioned that so
this information constraint I guess um
uh this information constraint matches
time Divergence also emerges in that
context of source coding and I feel even
Bob gray has some earlier papers on that
yes
I want to make one more calm that was
actually a great question because uh at
least in the gallery Richard that kind
of
I have only empirical distributions I
have only two distributions this is
broadly called generalization by Aurora
and others and this is sort of
called estimation by email you know it's
just a weird terminology to
differentiate the two quantities
I guess I'll call it access list yeah
yeah yeah because it's basically that's
what she's calling us yes because this
is the minimum risk you can have for
this problem right and this is the the
difference is the excess if you have to
tolerate because you weren't able to
solve the population problem and you
were only able to solve the empirical
problem but this is also unrealistic
because you never have the ground truth
py in any case so generalization is
really the right metric in the sense
that
how good does your learning algorithm do
relative to the statistical ground true
so in that sense
yeah I mean in practice when you don't
know this this may be difficult to
compute but I guess a theoretical result
is saying that whatever that is you're
guaranteed to converge to that optimal
uh basically with this rate here it is
parametric rate
um
the sound the real samples suppose
distribution you don't really know
this is this is in the following sense
right so I'm not assuming py is no I'm
just saying that whatever py is right as
long as I know it's just satisfies the
assumptions of the theorem then I know
that the optimal the the excess risk
will decrease to zero as
F squared into
I mean I may not be able to compute this
excess risk because I don't know this G
star in practice right but I'm ensured
that in this setting I will converge my
excess risk to go to zero as one almost
okay and I guess in the remaining part
um uh hopefully I have some I had some
10 minutes or so
okay okay
then in this last part I'll try to give
you one more application for this
information concern in Flash's time
Divergence again in the construct
context of washer Stein Gans
um and this is actually a simulation
here
um I guess before we go into that so
this is just to validate the theoretical
results here
um and these are experiments with the
gaussian distribution again because in
practice in order to compute your
distance to the optimal solution you
have to know what the optimal solution
is so that's why we chose to work with
the in the gaussian setting here and you
see that so this blue and green lines
they correspond to dance trained with
the loss function is the standard washer
sign distance and for this um for this
orange and red one here the loss is the
information regularized washer Stein
Divergence and you see that you converge
to the optimal distribution to the
optimal generator much faster with the
regularization as the theory suggests
and in some cases with the standard
washer sign distance actually you have a
uh you can be far away from from
Ophthalmology
okay so the next thing is basically how
we can use this uh for for privacy in
Gans
okay so a lot of times when we want to
learn a generative model for our data
the data may contain private and
sensitive information so maybe these are
images that users take with their mobile
phones right and they they may not want
to share their personal images with the
world uh just as they are with the
learner or the data curator
um and one possible solution in this
case can be to do the following you can
take the samples generated at the users
and you can first pass them through a
local privatization mechanism here M and
you share with the world with the
learner only the output of this
privatization mechanism uh only the
privatized sample Yi
and hopefully this privatization is done
in a way such that this Yi doesn't
reveal too much information about the
wrong sample UI I won't Define what
formally what the notion of local
differential privacy is but you can just
think of it as adding some sufficient
amount of noise to the sample so that
you are hiding the row sample so for
example if our samples here are images
from this MNS data set instead of
sharing these samples as they are you're
sharing this which is the kind of noisy
version of this so noise added so that
you're you're hiding the underlying
information
and the question we would like to ask in
this case is how can we train dance
from privatized samples from these y
eyes
um
and indeed we Face an immediate
challenge here because if you take the
Gan formulation from the previous slide
remember we want to find a generator
from a given class that minimizes the
washer Stein distance between the
generated distribution
um and the empirical distribution of our
samples so in this case we only have
privatized samples so if I use
privatized samples if I replace this
with the empirical distribution of the
privatized samples then I'll be training
a generator that generates the
privatized samples the noisy samples and
not the original samples right
so then the question is how how can I
modify this framework so that I
encourage my generator to generate the
raw data distribution rather than the
privatized data distribution
and I guess as you can guess at this
point in the talk the solution turns out
to be regularized with mutual
information okay so if you change your
loss function here the washer Stein
distance from the regular washer Stein
distance to the information regularized
washers time distance and you adjust the
regularization parameter collect
correctly then you you've this this
generator will actually generate the raw
data distribution even if you plug in
the privatized samples here
um and this is essentially the main
theorem here so this holds when the
privatization mechanism you use locally
for privatizing the samples is an
additive noise mechanism like LaPlace or
gaussian
um and in this case we are actually not
just interested in the quadratic washer
Stein distance but we are interested in
P washer spine distance more generally
so the difference now is that this cost
function that we hit here is not just
the squared Oblivion distance but it's
the P Norm raised to the power P this is
the P washer sign distance and turns out
that in order to get rid of that
privatization noise in order to
encourage the output of your generator
to generate the raw data distribution
you need to adjust you need to choose
the P here according to the tail decay
of your of your noise distribution so
maybe it's just easier to to go over the
two corollaries I had here
um
so somehow it feels like violating
deeply if you do this the whole idea of
synthetic uh data for like deeply
guarantees is to say that you know you
could actually net with a release a row
of the data set
through any kind of a general model
um so this is where I add noise I mean
this is a great question I still want to
be sampling from the original
distribution but what
is there a way to guarantee that that
is not differentially private yeah the
catch is that I'm not saying you'll be
able to recover the original samples I'm
just saying you will learn the
distribution from this from which these
samples are coming from and you'll be
able to sample from that distribution
um yeah but in a discrete setting that
could reveal if you know the support
then
you very much may have sampled from the
data set in that style I mean the local
differential so this may tell us
Epsilon or Epsilon Delta or whatever you
like and once you have that I mean those
guarantees hold for everything that
falls right and uh I mean that can't be
violated if it was probably Pro if it
was privatized then it's it's privatized
uh but I think the the catch is that I'm
not saying you're actually learning
these samples without noise I'm not
saying actually I'll show you examples
I'm not saying you can take this Yi and
you can recreate this UI
um for example this can be a face image
and this can be your noisy face image
I'm not saying I will be able to recover
your photo I'm just saying I'll be able
to learn and noiseless distribution for
generating human faces
um
at least theoretically okay so um
and I'll show you some results
um there are some limitations in the
results but I'll talk about that
okay so this is what it's saying so here
are the two corollaries that I'd like to
mention so if you're using the LaPlace
metallism as your privatization
mechanism in this case you should use
the one washer spine distance with
information regularization here and the
regularization parameter that Lambda has
to be chosen to match the noise scale of
the slap loss mechanism and this theorem
guarantees that if you were to plug in
the target distribution here sorry this
is the privatized distribution of the
samples this is the distribution from
which the privatized samples are
generated but if you minimize find the
best G here the output of that base G
the the output the generated
distribution will actually be equal to
the row distribution of the samples so
at the output of your generator you
won't be generating the privatized
distribution but you'll be generating
the global distribution this is what I'm
saying
and again in the case with with the
gaussian mechanism
now this in this case p is equal to 2 so
you should use the quadratic washer sine
distance with again information
regularization and this regularization
parameter has to match the snow scale
and same thing if you plug in here the
privatized distribution but you will
generate at the output of the optimal
generator will be the true distribution
the row distribution of the samples
mechanisms irrespective of whether the
input is discrete or not the output is
discrete or continuous
but if suppose my discrete data was just
two points if you did right you would
have to do randomized response in which
case you'll get your support questions
is not is taken care of but yes yes yeah
so every every sample now has a chance
to take on every value because it has to
because because
right so what I'm saying is then the
support is no longer the original
every sample can have full support this
is what you're saying every noise
example connected
and
we'll talk about it okay perfect
okay and okay so this is this is this is
assuming I have access to this
privatized distribution so I know the
distribution from which my privatized
samples are coming from but again just
like we said before in practice I don't
get to solve this problem I get to solve
this problem where I have the empirical
distribution of the privatized samples
um
okay and what we can show in this case
is a similar kind of uh convergence
result like in the previous case we can
show that this this empirical solution
GN converges to the
um optimal solution G Star which
generates the raw data distribution
again in this sense in a sense that this
difference here will converge to zero as
one over square root of n
um and now the the variance of the noise
comes here which means that if you want
to add more noise this means the
convergence will be slower so you'll
have to compensate by using more samples
here
to achieve the same the same
approximation here
okay and here are some experiments uh so
um
okay so here we are using MNS so these
are our original images samples
these are the privatized samples
and actually in order to
um we wanted to see whether these
privatized samples can reveal any
information about the underlying
original samples so here what we did was
we did wavelet denoising for these noisy
images and we were actually generous to
wavelet denoising because when we were
choosing the parameters of the wavelet
transform you use the original images
which violates the privacy and basically
you see that even if you do the optimal
denoising this noise is so much that you
don't recover at least in this context
we think you don't recover anything
useful about the individual images
and here we try a couple of things first
we train a regular uh Yan uh with a
regular washer Stein distance is our
loss function and we fit to this again
this privatized samples
and you see that with the regular washer
spine distance you don't learn anything
useful these are samples from the output
that are complete uh kind of garbage
the other thing we tried is we took this
denoest images and we fit these the
noise images to this uh regular washer
Stein Gan with uh with the bachelor's
time distance is the loss function and
again you can't get anything useful but
if you fit this privatized images to now
uh the washerstein again with
information regularization information
regularized you see that the output is
not perfect but you do generate
something that's useful okay so this is
just to kind of validate the claim that
regularizing the mutual information does
indeed inherently denoise the output
distribution and you are creating
um basically you're generating samples
or you are you're pending you're
converting to generating samples from
the original distribution of course not
perfect
uh and the kind of Epsilon Deltas we are
able to achieve here so the the Epsilon
and Delta guarantees for this
privatizations here in the first row
it's uh it's um we use the gaussian
mechanism and the Epsilon is 35 in the
second row it's the LaPlace mechanism
and the Epsilon is very large 196. so
the formal privacy guarantees are are
are are are are not there obviously we
want them to be but I think this is
saying something more about these being
uh this this metric being appropriate
for this context of images
rather than right because we typically
aim Epsilon around 10 or something at
least but I think you see here that I
don't think there is any any way you can
recover the original images but because
of the dimensionality of the sample the
kind of epsilons you you can you can
guarantee formally are quite large
and if you go for lower epsilons so here
uh basically in this first row
um we are we are using the LaPlace
mechanism again with information
regularized
um one washer Stein distance and the
Epsilon is 35 here and 25 here
um and here in the second row
um we use the gaussian mechanism now
um with uh again the the loss function
is
um information regularized now quadratic
washerstein Divergence and the epsilons
here are 30 here and 25 here if you go
lower than you you basically you you
don't um the quality degrades
significantly and and we think one of
the reasons is that the MNS data set is
pretty small uh so maybe the number of
samples we have are not enough to
compensate for the amount of noise be it
because our Theory suggests that if you
add more noise then you have to you need
more samples to be able to converge so
we're doing we're still working on
experiments so uh
um I mean we brought part of this but
part of this is still going on
okay so this was a proof for why adding
Mutual information denoises the output
but I think it's a little late for that
so I'll just Skip and uh I'll I'll just
conclude by saying that so in this talk
we talked about this notion of
information constraint optimal transport
I I talked about a a transportation cost
inequality for bounding this quantity we
talked about Connections to ISO
parametric results
um how it comes up in the solution of
covers problem and finally we talked
about how this information constraint
can be useful in achieving faster
convergence in against and also in the
last part achieving local differential
privacy
and this was based on these three papers
here
So yeah thank you and I'm happy
[Applause]
we have time for a couple of questions
with privacy uh do you need to make any
assumptions on the EU distribution
uh
well py has to be sub gaussian so
um so therefore
um
I guess um yeah I mean this is the
formal assumption the py meaning the
privatized samples that go here this
distribution has to be um has to be a
sub gaussian distribution the source for
both
uh
or actually the thing is that Behind
These convergence results only for the
W2 case so this is only for the gaussian
case
um we don't have the corresponding
results convergence result like this in
the case of W1
we think it may be doable but
we don't have it
exactly thank you for the very nice talk
like I was wondering if you could
comment on the role of dimensionality
also and the constant kfd because for
example MSC listen it is barely High
dimensional like 700 Dimensions so
um yeah this this KD right yeah this is
actually exponentially the yeah this
constant is exponentially it's always
exponential indeed in all these results
uh
um yeah I mean it seems like exponential
in D would be difficult to handle in
practice but these things still seem to
converge uh the other thing is that
um when you converge to something and
right and when you generate some samples
so so this is basically saying that
um
can you say something about how close
this generated distribution is to the
true distribution right
um it doesn't say uh basically this
generated distribution will not be close
to the empirical distribution of the
samples so in practice it may look like
you are converging to something right
but what you generate maybe just the
empirical distribution or something very
close to the empirical distribution of
the samples you may be memorizing those
samples and just regenerating them right
um
so basically in practice I guess we it
seems like we're generating something
um but again we don't know exactly what
we are generating right um and this is a
guarantee about how close you get to the
true distribution
uh there is another I'm gonna ask you a
question um
broadly in the dance literature do you
have a sense of what is a good measure
scam like is my best I secreted my own
self but broadly in the gas literature
do you know what's I mean why was Stein
I mean it's an IPM it's easy to work
with but
why not something
yeah
I mean well I'm advocating the
information regularized Russia's time
distance here it also has dual forms
similar to the washer Stein distance and
actually one advantage is that in the
Dual form you don't have constraints on
the functions like lipsense and
convexity so it may be easier to train
in practice I guess I don't have a good
answer for that but I'm here to Advocate
yeah most of us don't so I had to ask
you okay perfect but it was a great job
thank you thank you so much thank you
foreign
thank you
yeah